what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight spoiler video today I will be
reading season 8 episode 2 of the plot
leaked but before I do that I may be
showing you one of the biggest spoilers
of all time
this is actually going to be a talking
Thrones exclusive as of right now this
photo has not been made public by anyone
until right now and I have to thank my
friend over at Game of Thrones updates
on Instagram he was kind enough to send
me this photo before he posted it online
I will put the link to his page down
below in the description for those of
you who would like to give him a follow
he reached out to me just a few hours
ago and he said he wanted to send me a
photo that was taken from the set while
they filmed a game of Thrones Season 8
he knows someone that works for HBO and
they took this photo and they sent it to
him before I show you this I must give
you a disclaimer first I do not know how
real this is but you can definitely tell
who this is in the photo and if he's
right this will be arguably the biggest
scene in Game of Thrones history but I
will let you all be the judge of that
take a look at the photo right here that
is Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
according to this source
he says Jon Snow will kiss Daenerys
Targaryen in this scene then he will
plunge his sword into her art it could
possibly be a fake but then again maybe
it's not just take a look at the way the
actors are standing Jon Snow is leaning
forward as if he's about to make a
thrusting motion while Daenerys is
leaning back away from him almost as if
she's trying to lean out of the way I
don't think she'd be laning like that if
she was trying to kiss him if anything
she would still be leaning in for a kiss
I know some of you may be thinking John
doesn't even have his sword out but you
have to keep in mind he can't actually
stabbed an heiress with something all he
needs to do is make the thrusting motion
then they will add the sword the blood
in the fire during post-production they
would definitely have to do it all with
CGI since the sword needs to catch on
fire
while it's piercing her heart HBO very
well could have staged this but I think
if they wanted to spread misinformation
they would have leaked it to a bigger
site I doubt I would be the first person
to talk
about this if they wanted it to go viral
but then again maybe they were just
kissing if anything at all
whatever seeing this is from it must be
new because John and Daenerys have never
stood in the snow together yet
the only time Daenerys was in the snow
was when she went beyond the wall and
she never got off her dragon in those
scenes so let me know what you think
about this photo do you believe the
source or do you think it's [ __ ]
with this being the last season I think
just about anything is possible but I
want to know what you think about this
if the source is true that means
Daenerys dies in Jon Snow is azor Ahai
and this could reveal the ending of Game
of Thrones but now I want to move on to
the game of Thrones Season eight plot
leaked a few days ago I read season 8
episode 1 so now I want to read episode
2 I asked everyone if they wanted me to
continue reading more of this plot and
the response was overwhelming with
people saying yes read more so let's
begin season 8 episode 2 the opening
scene is at Winterfell
Davos Ken jury and the remaining forces
arrive at Winterfell main gate they
agreed to stay behind with the ships in
order to unload the rest of the dragon
glass that was mined on Dragonstone
they have several big wagons full of
dragonglass most of the wagons are full
of black obsidian but there are also a
few filled with green and red dragon
glass Arya Brienne and Podrick are
outside training in the yard until they
hear all the commotion at the gate they
see all of the wagons of dragonglass
being brought into the center of the
courtyard as they are watching this area
and ginjury spot each other from across
the yard
Arya can't believe who she is seeing
Arya and Gendry meet halfway and they
embrace for several moments they both
seem to be at a loss for words they
didn't expect to see each other again
in fact Arya says she thought Gendry was
dead she says she didn't trust that red
witch to that took him gangs relook said
Davos and says I would be dead if it
wasn't for him
Gendry says he knows why the gold cloaks
wanted him so bad he is King Robert's
bastard son Davo says that's exactly why
Gendry is here he was born to carry
hammer just like his father Gendry will
be working in your forges now preparing
weapons for the wars to come aria seems
pleased by this aria says she used to
recite Melisandre's name every night
before she went to sleep Aria says if I
ever see Melisandre again but Davos cuts
her off Davo says I will kill her the
next scene is in volantis and there is a
large group gathered outside of the red
temple overlord Melisandre can Vora
and several others are standing at the
top of the steps overlooking the crowd
Melisandre begins to say there is a
darkness falling of her Westeros and
soon it could cover us all role or has
placed me here for one purpose and one
purpose only and that's to end the
darkness Melisandre says I have already
brought ice and fire together I have met
the prince who was promised and he will
be the one who leads to fight against
the great other I have seen it in the
flames every time I look all I see is
snow the crowd begins to erupt some
people start chanting Daenerys Targaryen
the dragon queen can Vora steps forward
to silence the crowd she says prince or
princess it doesn't matter now
Melisandre is right the great other is
here ice and fire have been made as one
and they will fight together but we all
have a part to play in the great war
they cannot fight this alone
we must go to Westeros and help them all
of us in the next scene the aftermath at
Castle black will be shown all of the
whites that came were burnt Castle black
is in ruins everything had to be burned
in order to stop the attack of the
whites Lord Commander Ed was killed
during the attack along with 95% of the
remaining men that were still guarding
the wall here beric Dondarrion burns the
bodies with his sword he tells the few
remaining men he must go south he
promised someone he would see them again
and until he fulfills his purpose he
must continue the next scene is at
Winterfell in the godswood in Bahrain
Stark is alone at the weirwood tree his
hands are gripping his chair in his eyes
are fluttering
then it will show a series of visions
brain is having he sees Jamie Lannister
taking off his helmet the first time he
arrived at Winterfell he sees his father
statue in the crypts of Winterfell
he sees and hears the Mad King saying
burned them all pots a wildfire or in a
cellar blue dragon fire is burning a
castle and someone is in a bed of blood
and there is the sound of a baby crying
bran falls from the tower bran can see
smoke rising from Winterfell and he sees
Melisandre looking into the flames he
sees a black silhouette of someone
holding a sword that is on fire
bran is falling from the tower window
then he comes face-to-face with the
night king and he immediately comes out
of his vision struggling to breathe when
Brian looks up he is surrounded by Jon
Daenerys Tyrion Sansa Arya Davos Varys
Brienne and his master John asks bran
what happened what did he see brain says
everything I can see everything at first
it was all fragments and I struggled to
distinguish what was past or present but
now I know brian says Castle black is
gone along with its men the last hearth
is gone along with the umbers he says
that the night king has seen him and he
knows they are there and he is coming
John tells everyone to meet him in the
main hall as John begins to walk away
bran grabs him by the arm brain says we
need to speak soon it's time you know
the truth everyone of importance has
gathered in the main hall at Winterfell
John informs everyone of the recent
attacks in the north by the night king
he says the Great War will begin soon
and they must be prepared John says he
doesn't know if Cersei will be sending
her support or not but they will have to
work with what they have the castle
walls will need extra reinforcements and
all of the dragon glass needs to be
fashioned into weapons that way every
man woman and child can arm themselves
John says that when Tyrell should not
fall but if it does there are secret
passages they can use to flee the north
but he hopes it doesn't come to that
Daenerys still has two dragons and fire
kills whites
he also says his sword has made a
Valyrian steel so he can take out as
many White Walkers as he can Brienne and
Arya both stand up at the same time they
too have Valyrian steel and they will
stand by John and help him Samwell Tarly
stands up in the back of the hall
he tells John he also has a Valyrian
steel sword he says he took his father's
sword before he left horn Hill he also
says he has been reading some of the old
books he took from the Citadel and he
may have found some things that may be
of interest
Tyrion shifts in his seat and says I
would like to see some of these books as
well as everyone starts to leave the
hall Daenerys tells John she would like
to have a word with him alone Sansa
looks at Daenerys suspiciously as does
Tyrion they both walk atop the castle
overlooking the battlements
Daenerys wants to know if John plans on
telling everyone about their
relationship John doesn't think that's a
good idea right now considering tensions
were already high when they arrived in
the first place John says what the night
King being so close we should wait to
tell everyone later the last thing I
need is everyone walking out of here now
we can't afford to lose anyone Cersei
may never send help
and we already lost the Nights Watch and
the umbers as John begins to walk away
Daenerys says wait there's one more
thing I saw your maester last night
because I wasn't feeling too well John I
am pregnant in the next scene Jaime and
Bronn arrive at the twins the property
looks nearly abandoned at the time Jaime
says someone infiltrated their castle
and poisoned almost everyone here but
surely someone is still ruling the
castle no one is guarding the bridge
Jaime says if only the young wolf found
their bridge this way he would still be
alive in my family most likely dead when
Jaime and Bronn reached the door they
are greeted by several woman that are
now ruling the twins Jaime says they are
heading north and he needs to gather any
men are soldiers that he can there is a
storm coming down from the wall and
everyone will die unless they come with
them one of the girls says Queen Cersei
didn't send
any word about this then Jamie says no
she sent me instead sir see Qyburn and
the mountain are walking around the
walls of King's Landing
Qyburn has men bringing up the stashes
of wildfire the place at each gate that
enters of the city no one will enter
through a gate without getting burned
alive men are also seen setting up the
ballistas
Qyburn has had several more made and now
they are being strategically placed
around the Red Keep and they're all
aiming at the sky King's Landing will
not fall easy
Qyburn tells Cersei that urine has
picked up the golden company and they
should arrive in King's Landing any day
now Cersei is pleased she says they may
have a larger army right now but she
will never step foot inside this city
alive
even if they lose we have seen what fire
does to the dead with the amount of
wildfire we have I am NOT concerned with
an attack from anyone right now now that
I have the iron banks full support I may
have one more surprise for our foreign
horror the next scene is at night at the
Iron Islands Theon and his small team
land their boat on the shore and begin
to make their way up they plan on
entering the castle and freeing his
sister Yara to their surprise no one was
left to guard the place it is completely
abandoned Euron has taken every able
body with him and killed the rest who
could not fight or row Yara is not there
Theon's worst fear has come true
Yara is still one decides and he will
have to board that wicked ship to free
her the next scene is on the silence in
your ax is down below and she's covered
in blood what most of her hair cut off
she's tied up but she's not gagged
Joran enters and begins laughing
maniacally at her he begins to taunt her
by telling her she will die on this ship
he says Theon will never have the balls
to attempt to get her back and if he
does he will hang them both from the
front of his ship then he leans down and
says tell me Yara who is your king Yara
doesn't say a word and for a few moments
it's silent until Euron begins laughing
again and he hits Yara with her own
tongue
Yara begins to cry Sam Brandt Aryan and
the Meister are looking over everything
he took from the Citadel Sam says he has
books and Scrolls about the long night
the others the children of the forest
and much more but he can't make sense of
it all tyrion picks up the book that was
already open about the long night he
starts reading it aloud
it's about azor Ahai and his sword
called light bringer tyrion is intrigued
he says it reminds him of something
Melisandre once said while she was at
Dragonstone
Melisandre said the prince who was
promised would bring the dawn yet
missandei believes it could mean
princess bran says it sounds similar to
the stories old nan used to tell him
about the last hero the man who would
lead to fight against the dead the
maester says where do you suppose we
find such a man with this magical sword
Sam and Tyrion both look at brand and
brand says take me to the weirwood tree
the last scene will be at the car hold a
massive storm begins to roll in from the
north everyone in the area begins to go
indoors
Elise Karstark is inside with a few men
reading over some messages delivered by
the Ravens that day she said that word
has came from Winterfell
the Nights Watch no longer stands in the
last hearth was destroyed the wall no
longer protects us from what lies beyond
the king in the North wants us to
prepare for the worst
he is arming everyone at Winterfell and
I've already sent men to get some of the
dragon class that he says can be used
against them but before she can finish
telling her men about the news from
Winterfell a sudden scream and the sound
of a horn begins to echo through the
castle
Elise runs over to the window and looks
outside it's a complete whiteout from
the storm
she can't see anything past their wall
then an ear-shattering scream comes from
the clouds the night king and Viserion
break through the storm in a blue flame
is seen lighting up the night sky our
eat folks that was episode 2 let me know
what you think about all of this put
your thoughts and questions down below
and let me know if you want me to read
every episode because I will if you want
me to
I want to thank everyone for taking the
time out of their day to check out the
video I hope you enjoyed it and I also
want to thank all of my new patreon
supporters I am amazed by how many of
you kind people continued to help out
the channel it truly means a lot and
your support fuels me to keep making as
many videos as possible so thank you all
for the extra motivation have a great
day everyone
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
you